we got this story from timcast.com
Disney's Ultra woke Willow series
canceled after one season oh so uh it's
not just this one show but I'll use this
article as a launching Point Netflix is
getting rid of a lot of these shows they
canceled their their non-binary Ox story
or whatever I don't know if you guys saw
that no yeah it's like a preschool show
where an ox is like I'm non-binary and I
don't like she uh he is she her so I'm
they them and they're like okay and then
Netflix is like get rid of this that is
the worst a non-binary ox for children
so they're starting to get rid of all
this stuff and Netflix is seeing their
subscriptions Grow Again nice so they
they dipped really hard I think this is
evidence that it was the boycott
campaign from conservatives that really
hurt their bottom line and caused them
to shift and go back and I also want to
give a shout out to a show called the
order one of the only shows I've ever
seen were the villains a communist
interesting season two you should watch
it they canceled it like they were all
like wow on Netflix yeah it's on Netflix
it's called the order and and they did
two seasons and then canceled it but the
second season the bad guy's a communist
he's a communist University Professor
I'll check it out that's no fascinating
yeah like a communist University
Professor is a bad guy I think I was
like this is great I love this show
because I like politics
they even made that like it sounds like
something to be like no it's just too
crazy I think conservatives started
boycotting over cuties yeah that was the
thing I think what's happened as as we
just did this long discussion on what
wokeness is these companies are starting
to realize that ESG and weakness hurt
your bottom line good because that's the
only reason they were adopting it I
think in the first place they thought it
helped yes they were like this is what
people like and then and then sure
enough if you implement a Diversity
Program at your company because you want
to fit in and then a year later let's
say this let's say you hired a diversity
equity and inclusion you know a chief
Equity officer or whatever and now
Bernie Sanders just went on Bill Maher
and said we don't want any of that now
would he do fire the guy
whoa we did this thing because on a whim
left us that they liked it now they
don't like it anymore we don't fit in
anymore oh God get rid of it I mean but
think about this Bernie Sanders says no
no we don't want Equity Jen Huger then
comes out and says I agree we don't so
if you're a company that has it you're
out of line you no longer fit in the
left is gonna throw a brick through your
window because you're so you're you're
opposing Bernie Sanders now it's too bad
these people don't have self-reflection
because there's zombies with no shame
yeah well zombies can't reflect on
anything they've grown you know but they
do have Reflections yes vampires don't
though
there's no way a vampire can see its own
reflect can never reflect on it but you
know vampires can think
yeah like like a vampire is likely
vampires are more like CEOs of big
companies you know big neo-liberal crony
corporate yeah institutions yeah they
just extract value they're conscious of
what they're doing and they don't care
except apparently Vanguard so vanguard's
pulled out of the CSG stuff have you
been following I was not aware that
Vanguard had pulled out of ESG that's
really interesting it's like a 20 how
big is this fund it's about nine times
smaller than BlackRock Vanguard is nine
times it's based out of Pennsylvania
yeah this is American company and the
CEO basically just stepped up and was
like it's not profitable we're done
we're taken back we're aiming at profit
first for our investors we're not going
to screw you guys over by putting your
money into things that don't return
money yeah basic but that's that that's
how economics works that's why I think
why free market a lot of times problem
with free markets is not free it's
co-opted by people at the top it's like
socialism for the few we just we got to
have more economic literacy campaigns so
that people can start to understand it
it's it's going to be a long long haul
but we got to start at the beginning and
just start educate have you talked to
Vivek ramaswamy I have not spoken to him
wow now that would be a unification for
him to come because he is like the
economic Guru that guy yeah to be able
yeah if he can interlock with the
libertarian party he's running as a
republican right now for president he
was just in New Hampshire I think some
of the New Hampshire Libertarians were
were interested in his campaign we'll
we'll see what happens I'm all about
Austrian economics and economic literacy
that's why I'm like so into mises and
that whole you know path
and when you argue with someone who
calls for a command economy or for the
nationalization of banks you're you know
that they've not read anything correct
and they don't know how Finance works at
all it's funny when people talk about
like our tax dollars paying for this
that or otherwise and it's just like
that's not how it works
they just they just manufacture money
it's just it's like a meme it goes Burr
yeah they they the the modern monetary
system is nonsensical it's just like
when they want money it's just there
they have it you just ask Mom and Dad
yeah if that the banks just create money
upon demand for a loan exactly the money
supply just keeps growing infinitely and
I heard these people on I was listening
to a space on Twitter and they were like
Finance guys and they're talking about
fractional Reserve policy and I'm like
the FED is we covered this in in 2021 or
whatever yeah like when they got when
Ian brought it up when they dropped the
reserve requirements and that's an
infinite Reserve System where they can
just loan at an infinite number amount
of money with no restrictions exactly
they make it seem as if the fed's doing
it but it's not it's just Banks I mean
if that does it too quantitative
quantitative easing is a thing yes they
want to inject debt-free money into the
system well it's not debt-free but they
want to inject money into the system to
the government things like that but the
uh it used to be a nine to one for every
or like 90 for every 100 they could loan
out 90. and then I think Ian pointed out
they updated in March of 2020 they were
going on to an infinite Reserve System
where Banks could infinitely loan out
money without any any reserve
requirements here's what the lion shares
there there's a quote from the Fed chair
of many at the minute Indianapolis Fed
chair Neil Kashkari from put it
memorably on 60 Minutes in March 2020
quote there's an infinite amount of cash
in the Federal Reserve we will do
whatever we need to make sure there's
enough cash in the banking system
Infinity dollars
so I think that's a good
message to me I'm not giving advice to
anybody to buy Bitcoin and yeah maybe
some gold I mean that's a moronic
statement to say that there is infinite
and that we will do we need to make
enough you can't have enough in an
infinite system it's this is it's like
it's like children just making things up
except these are the people in charge of
our finance yeah it's like it's like
literally everything against what I
learned to get a degree in econ it's
like it's it's totally it's uh we're
just I don't even know what to say when
you were studying for your degree did
they talk about how corrupt stuff was
well I was told that stagflation will
never happen it'll never happen like
this will never be a thing don't worry
about it don't consider it it'll never
happen hey look at that white shot here
we are stagflation how can you define
that really quick uh stagnant stagnating
inflation where of inflation but we
don't have the ability to create any
more wealth out of the situation so you
give you there's you're basically just
stuck in a situation it's like this
they're like oh but it'll never happen I
was told so many times it'll never
happen but here so like where you want
to buy steel from a different country
but your money is worth so little that
you can't even afford the steel to buy
the factory so yeah that would be
interesting I'll just I'll just give you
the dictionary definition it's
persistent High inflation combined with
high unemployment and stagnant demand in
a country's economy
costs are going up and everything else
is just Frozen so it's like it's really
bad you can't do you can't do anything
you're stuck just is nothing you can do
you can't affect any change you've got
to find a really cheap way to start a
new industry I like this pulling carbon
dioxide out of the air concept for that
yeah it's a almost in your infinite
resource you know Airborne carbon
more trees just plant burnt trees burn
trees plant more trees burn trees burn
more trees and more carbon that could
get us like from zero to a hundred uh to
get things started if we need to kick
start our economy but it's not going to
happen with the old style what uh just
somebody uh
some of the chats saying they were this
guy named Blake saying that they were
told that too that sagflation would
never happen that was like a thing that
I was told I would never ever happen
it's never going to be a thing don't
worry about it don't even don't even
think about how to solve it don't think
about it it's never gonna be an issue
then modern monetary policy comes in and
now it's like it's just nmt is like the
Witchcraft of Economics you should not
it's crazy you should not dabble no one
no one knows no one knows what's gonna
happen no one has any real understanding
what's gonna happen because it's all
it's an experiment we're it we're
basically in an experiment right now we
don't really it's it's theoretically
this is how it should work yes
theoretically it's going to be okay but
we don't know modern monetary theory is
the idea that if you control if your
country controls the outflow of money if
you control the currency you can make as
much as you want that you can print as
much as you want and there's no there's
going to be no drawback because you
control it so you can always make more
and nothing can ever stop it or make it
go bad that's the stupid Theory that's
an actual theory that you can print
unlimited amounts of money if you
control it yep that's so so wrong
because you that's a sort of inflation
if you keep it it's printing money
centralizing the economy it means that
you can then
when if if everybody in this table had a
dollar and was trading that dollar for
goods like Ian I'll give you a dollar
for that water and then I have the water
and then Angela's like I'll give you a
dollar for that water and we're trading
this water the money's all moving it's
an economy surge then writes on a piece
of paper one dollar and then walks up
and goes I will give you one dollar for
this water and you go I like this and he
takes your water and leaves now we're
all sitting here holding dollars with no
water and we're like wait what just
happened
he provided nothing he did no work for
the community he gave no real trade this
is what the US government has been doing
I I shouldn't say so much the government
the FED what basically happens is we all
work for each other you know what it is
holy crap the best way to understand
this is the Google box from Rick and
Morty all right I don't know what that
is so Rick's car breaks down and then he
has a battery with the mini verse in it
or a microverse whatever he calls it
sure a miniature Universe where a
civilization of people generate energy
by stepping on these pads and then he
takes a portion of energy to power his
car and they don't realize there and
then and then Morty's like extracting
the value yes and Morty goes isn't this
just slavery with extra steps he goes no
no they work for each other they trade
that's what the Federal Reserve is we
all work for each other we all do trade
and then as we're trading these dollars
the dollars have value because we
believe in each other because I know
that Ian wants dollars Ian is willing to
do work for dollars so the economy
functions I say Ian here's a dollar come
on the show and talk about magnetism and
he says that's a good good idea for me
the US government does no work and then
just manufactures the dollar right and
then walks in injects into the system to
take from Ian Ian is then convinced to
do work on behalf of the government who
did no work in return because they
control the flow of money right there
was no value and when there's five value
just extracted from the system it goes
to them they're no value created for the
system at all it's just yeah when
there's four of us each trading a dollar
and then surge comes in with his piece
of paper dollar and hands it in now
we've got four of us that dollar I guess
is lost or we have no like no no no
there's five dollars and no water and
and one of the dollars is worth zero so
now each of our dollars is worth 80
cents we have to divide it up and
balance it out remember that a dollar is
a is a store of value the idea is that
it holds value value is it's like you'd
say will bring like a hundred goats to a
market a trade for like you know a
thousand whatever you just bring it it's
a medium of exchange yeah it's a medium
exchange exactly you don't need it
doesn't it's like it just is represents
value so what Tim is saying is the value
is well I'll put it this way promissory
no so Ian
you have a dollar we all have a dollar
and you have the water and we're all
Trading
when search comes to you and says I'll
give you a dollar for your water you now
have two dollars
then when Hannah Claire comes to you and
says I'll give you a dollar for water
you go I already have two I don't need
it
I don't need your dollar I got a dollar
from him
well oh now Hannah Claire can't buy from
you because you're uninterested working
for it because you got too much money so
then she has to pay more I said well how
much do I have to give you to do the
work and you go well I already got two
dollars so I don't know two more but it
was a dollar yesterday well I already
have a dollar I don't need yours thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time